dean colby says what are your three
favorite novels
i
i don't have
more than one favorite book and that's
gerdle escherbach i don't think i have a
second
i do have
two books that i frequently and only
recommend on this channel i think
there's only been two books by people
who are living sorry by people who have
been on the
toe channel that's carlo rivelli's the
order of time i believe it's called and
then another is
ian mcgill chris master and his emissary
i thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed those
books i also love girdle escherbach
douglas hofstadter hasn't been on the
program so i don't include him in that
but i recommend that wholeheartedly
matthew wallace says hello kurt how do
you avoid existential dread
barely
matthew though i'm i'm thinking of doing
a stand-alone podcast on
the dark knight of the soul much like
how i read jacob smallian's
god is a taoist which is one of my
favorite pieces on this channel it's the
musings of a mathematician on free will
from a zen perspective
couched in the chronicle of a man
speaking to god begging god to release
him from the burden of free will just me
thinking about doing a reading of the
dark night of a soul sorry the dark
knight of the soul and doing some
commentary on it
it provokes me slightly
it agitates me and i think that that may
be a reason why i should
do it as a form of therapy for myself
and perhaps
hopefully others it may quell my own
existential dread recontextualize it to
not be so terrifying and debilitating
i've also talked about the dark knight
of the soul on the diana pasulka podcast
which will be around here and the chloe
valderri podcast in some ways it's about
ego death
though perhaps the term
ego death should be ego transformation
or liberation or metamorphism or
integration
because it can feel like dying but
i don't think ego death is the right
term i think it's a
well it's a provocative term
there's light though there's wonderful
beams of light of
a wonderful wondrous
beneficent beatific place
of
of goodness
that can come from it
as
a
a place that's
that's helpful and
and supporting and shielding and
generous
and tranquil
and calming and loving so i don't know
if ego death is the right
term i would prefer to
have a different terminology i feel like
my issue with
with toe what's happened is that i've
been
hypothesizing and hypothetizing
far too much
it's
it's a huge huge huge cognitive
effort sorry it's a huge imposition in
some ways to go through someone's toe
and then
jump to another one and then jump to
another one and jump to another one it's
extremely
psychologically
unsettling like that's to say the least
it's unsettling
it's
something that i
thinking about toes and thinking about
how to make sense of certain facts and
not even facts how to make sense of what
it means to make sense is something that
consumes me unceasingly virtually every
single minute
of
every waking day for the past few months
and by the way sometimes even the
sleeping days that that is to say not
just in my wakeful moments but when i
sleep though i love it i don't i
actually like nightmares i rarely get
them but i
i have a perverse relationship to
nightmares because i believe that
they're regenerative in some manner that
i'm facing a fear and hey i would much
rather face it there than face it in a
in the waking life i used to believe
that people who say you should be
open-minded but not so open-minded that
your head falls out
i used to feel like they betray a
certain idea of god because what they're
doing is
following not following truth they're
following what it means to survive and
to put their health above
objective truth or something higher than
themselves
that is to say how do you know you
crossed a line
until you've crossed it even even then
you don't know because many people who
have gone mad quote unquote don't
believe themselves to be mad and it's
difficult to know when one's head has
fallen out but i see the utility in that
phrase and i never saw it before i used
to see that as being a
statement that's less about searching
for the truth and more about justifying
the perimeter of lines that you've
already established shouldn't be crossed
so it's a statement of anti-truth but
now i see that there's
there's ex there well
there's extreme danger what it feels
like to awaken if that's even what it
what is the case is it's
it's like uh
at least now it feels like i'm in a daze
i mean i'm i'm
while i'm awake it's it's at least not
horrific anymore there are moments of
lucidity which happen more and more and
more frequently think
thank god thank the universe think
whatever it may be i feel much more
grounded i feel more eagerly sorry my
ego feels more grounded and it's
extremely pleasant
and now i've come to the
conclusion that perhaps one shouldn't
have an open mind necessarily one should
have an open heart but that's not the
same as an open mind an open heart comes
first
i don't think that the terror is worth
the trade
i think that love should be primary